porter junior inbounds it to jokic
almost knocked away they get the steal
bars for the lead
couldn't punch it tipped up no will it
count
buddy ball call game
run buddy run oh
sacramento with a tip and get out of
town
for the victory oh
man so many questions a wild
unfathomable
inexplicable sequence
barnes had it partially blocked
but buddy healed had his back
all the way back there mark jones
and counted doug who is he mark jones
paco my bad sent him home
buddy hill look at this tip
oh yeah that's right before the lights
went on
on the backboard by rule it's reviewed
but buddy's not sticking around doug the
defensive effort by harrison barnes not
given an
inch and then kicking it out harrison
went for the hammer smart
move buddy with the soft hands and the
touch
all the way from the bahamas
[Music]
great tireless
indefatigable effort at the defensive
end
by sacramento barnes just dogged effort
knocked it loose from jokic fox with the
nice touch on the pass
and then buddy healed off the miss
oh they earned this one mark oh they did
oh arnd they deserved
a positive fate as sacramento
wins it 124 120
they end an odious
six-game losing streak in the mile high
city nobody's going to catch buddy
tonight all you're going to see is his
shoe bottoms folks
he is gone and so are the nuggets
vanquished by sacramento